Ok, so we take the top off. We add a match.
The Barking Dog experiment was one of the
most famous experiments
and favourite experiments that was done by
my former colleague,
Colonel B.D. Shaw.
So Neil and I are preparing for one of my
favourite reactions. It’s called
the Barking Dog reaction. This is a reaction
which actually makes an
element and we’re going to make some sulphur
today. So the reaction’s
quite cool.
In the Barking Dog experiment you have a mixture
of the molecule
carbon disulphide, CS2. It’s just like carbon
dioxide but…wait a minute
I’m…
So this is a test tube, a rather large test
tube, of laughing gas, N2O, and
we’re going to use this to make some sulphur.
So I have a model here. So it’s CS2 which
has a carbon in the middle and
sulphurs at either end. So it looks just like,
in a model, as a molecule of
CO2, but it has sulphur there and there. And
this molecule, CS2, will react
with laughing gas, N2O.
So where are we going to do this now?
In the dark somewhere.
So essentially you are just using the laughing
gas as a sort of oxygen to
burn this molecule.
What we are actually going to do is generate
a lot of light. It used to be
used as a flash, for cameras and for photography.
What happens is you get a very bright emission
of a sort of bluish purple
light, which in the old days was used for
taking photographs before
people had flash-lamps on their cameras. They
would set this off and it
would give a great flash of light which could
be used to take
photographs. But because it’s much slower
than a flash it makes people
really have quite a surprised look and this
may well be why, in old
photographs, people look so surprised because
"My god, this thing has
gone off, Whoosh!"
So we’re on the hunt for a very dark place.
In the tube, as the reaction takes place it
generates heat.
Ok, so into the small lecture theatre which
is vacant now. It’s quite nice
because we can turn all the lights off and
make it a bit darker and see
this reaction in its, sort of, best.
So we’ve managed to create a darker environment
so we can really see
the benefits from this chemistry, and Neil’s
put some water in the bottom
of the tube. And we’re going to put about
6-8 millilitres of carbon
disulphide into this tube, and a good mix
so you can be sure that we get
all of that carbon disulphide going into the
later phase so that it’ll react
really quite quickly with all of that oxygen,
the N2O.
As the flame goes down the tube it accelerates
because the reaction’s
going faster and faster so it gives this great
sort of ‘whoop’ noise.
Now then, that was a really, really energetic
reaction because the
organic and the oxygen were all in the same
phase and the reaction got
a lot faster. The noise it made got a lot
louder as it went down because
of pressure. So what you can see in the tube
here is actually the result
or the aim of our chemical reaction today
because we wanted to make
some sulphur. So what we’ve got here, coated
on the inside of this tube,
is a thin layer of polymeric sulphur. So you
can see all this really quite
nice sulphur coating the inside of the glass
flask itself. Now I’m really
fortunate because I’m just going to go back
to my office and prepare a
lecture and leave Neil to clean this.
Thanks.
What are you doing mate?
Well I’ve just filled up my vessel with some
oxygen. So this is liquid
oxygen which we made for an earlier demonstration,
and we’ve just
used it to drive off all of the non-combustible
nitrogen form inside this
glass vessel. Well look at all that oxygen
floating around inside the
bottom of that flask, that’s really cool.
All oscillating - a really nice
experiment.
Yeah this is a really quite crazy jar. It’s
a small amount of sulphur, or
‘suphur’, that we’ve decanted out and unfortunately
when we decanted it
out we spelt the name wrong so…
Who’s responsible for that?
Err, it’s a…very old friend of mine and
I couldn’t possibly…give you his
identity as he would be really, really angry.
Wouldn’t he, Neil?
Yeah I’m saying nothing.
And it wasn’t Neil.
It wasn’t me.
So here we’ve got a small amount of sulphur
that we are going to put on
the tip of this spoon. So you can see it’s
starting to melt. Now with the
top, so it’s on fire and then we’ll just
drop it into the flask. And you can
see that that sulphur’s burning really intensely
now, with a really quite
beautiful flame. It’s generating a lot of
SO2, really smelly, which is why
we are doing it inside this fume cupboard
and you can see this really rich
intense blue flame as that sulphur is burning
in that excess oxygen in
that atmosphere.
Ok so this is actually a sort of geological
sample of sulphur. So you can
see it’s actually on the bottom, we’ve actually
got a rock and the sulphur
crystals have actually formed on top of it.
So actually, sulphur does
occur naturally. I think it’s been known
since ancient times so, you
know, when sermons are being delivered, fire
and brimstone, was
because hell is supposed to smell like sulphur,
which is brimstone. But
actually sulphur itself doesn’t actually
smell, but what you are smelling,
the ‘sulphury’ smell, is actually oxidised
material and hydrogen sulphide.
Well it’s actually a mixture of sulphur and
sand that was picked up by
one of my colleagues on his honeymoon, though
you see he was actually
thinking about chemistry even on his honeymoon,
though I don’t think
he told his wife that.
I have a feeling but I could wrong that I
bought this sample in
Oxfordshire where I used to live and I think
it’s actually from Brazil,
though I could be wrong.
So as we are using up all the sulphur now
the flame will die down until
eventually it will go out. Cool, there you
go.